guten Abend hallo zusammen willkommen zu
ZDF heute live die Ukraine kommt mit
ihrer Gegenoffensive gut voran und hat
in den letzten Tagen einiges an Gebieten
zurückerobern können das Feiern die
einen schon als die Wände im Krieg die
anderen sagen Vorsicht erstmal abwarten
wir wollen heute zum einen über die
militärische Lage sprechen das werden
wir tun mit oberstad Wolfgang Richter
und dann wollen wir noch schauen wie
diese Verluste in Russland aufgenommen
werden hier sehen wir Ausschnitte aus
einer Talkshow im russischen
Staatsfernsehen wo es wirklich ans
Eingemachte ging die Kriegsführung wurde
heftig kritisiert und damit natürlich
auch Präsident Putin darüber sprechen
wir später im Stream mit dem Russland
Experten und Blogger Nico lange jetzt
gibt uns erstmal Antoine kushigen einen
Überblick über die aktuelle Lage in der
Ukraine
ein Kraftwerk in Haake steht in Flammen
getroffen von einer russischen Rakete
sagt Kiew die Angriffe auf die zivile
Infrastruktur seien ein Racheakt für die
Erfolge der ukrainischen Armee und die
kommt im Osten offenbar immer weiter
voran und hat jetzt auch die lange
umkämpfte Stadt easium zurückerobert wie
diese Bilder der ukrainischen Armee
zeigen sollen
das ist der zentrale Platz von easium
das Gebäude der lokalen Verwaltung
brennt noch immer alles ist zerstört
aber es ist okay wir werden alles wieder
aufbauen
seit Anfang September hat das
ukrainische Militär offenbar mehr als
3000 Quadratkilometer im Osten
zurückerobert was auch den Menschen in
Kiew Mut macht
wir sind unseren Streitkräften unseren
Jungs und den mutigen Helden sehr
dankbar die Ukraine wird sich
durchsetzen ich bin optimistisch was die
Gegenoffensive betrifft sie muss
fortgesetzt werden bis die ganze Ukraine
befreit ist
dieses Ziel liegt wohl noch in weiter
Ferne doch die russische Armee kommt
offenbar immer mehr in die Defensive
sie und ihr könnt natürlich Fragen
stellen einfach in die Chats posten oder
eben eine E-Mail schreiben die werden
dann halt dann gleich Nico lange stellen
und Oberst ad Wolfgang Richter guten
Abend Herr Richter
schönen guten Abend
was würden Sie sagen ist dass die Wände
im Kriegsverlauf
ich glaube es ist noch keine
strategische Wände also das Ende des
Krieges ist noch nicht absehbar aber es
ist schon ein großer Erfolg für die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte sie haben die
Initiative wieder gewonnen es ist das
zweite Mal in diesem Krieg das erste Mal
war es ja Ende März Anfang April das
russische Truppen ein größeren Abschnitt
der vorher eroberten Gebiete zurückgeben
müssen das war damals vor Kiew und jetzt
geschieht ähnliches im Raum schalkev
jetzt ist es aber nicht mehr auf eine
Fehlbeurteilung der ukrainischen
Widerstandskraft zurückzuführen sondern
offensichtlich auf erhebliche Mängel bei
den russischen Streitkräften bei der
Führung und der Koordinierung der
verschiedenen Waffensysteme aber auch
bei der Aufklärung und der Reaktion auf
das was man sieht die Ukraine haben es
geschafft zwei Schwerpunkte gleichzeitig
zu bilden nämlich in Person einerseits
im Südwesten und eben an Nordosten weil
Carl kiff und sie haben die innere Linie
nutzen können das heißt durch die z
Ukraine können Sie Truppen natürlich
leichter verschieben als die Russen die
Halbmondform mich auf einer sehr sehr
langen Frontlinie angegriffen haben und
immer an der Peripherie um das Zentrum
herumtruppen verschieben müssen und sie
haben die Russen kalt erwischt kann man
so sagen das waren auch schwächere
Truppen die dort waren und sehr lenzke
selber hat ja viel dazu beigetragen dass
die Öffentlichkeit und auch wohl die
russische Seite glaubte der Schwerpunkt
der Operation liegt im Südwesten
tatsächlich liegt da jetzt bei krakev
die Ukraine haben also die Initiative
zurückgewonnen sie haben die Russen in
die Defensive gedrängt und es werden
jetzt sehr viele Mängel in der
russischen Führung und Koordinierung der
Truppen sichtbar
vielleicht am gravierendsten die
Tatsache dass sie weder in der Lage sind
Reserven einen gegenschwerpunkt zu
bilden wo man sich dann fragt was wo war
die Aufklärung wie reagiert man darauf
und schon gar nicht in der Lage waren
größere Truppenbewegung dieser gegeben
haben muss mit ihren Luftstreitkräften
zu verhindern das Gefechtsfeld
abzuregeln das ist nicht gelungen obwohl
die Russen ja eigentlich eine materielle
Überlegenheit in der Luft haben fast von
zehn zu eins und dann noch nach 200
Kriegstagen funktioniert es nicht die
russische
Luftangriffs gemacht war nicht in der
Lage die ukrainische Luftverteidigung
auszuschalten es fliegen immer noch
ukrainische Luftstreitkräfte und das ist
schon ein deutliches Zeichen und
vielleicht ein letztes Wort was die
Achillesferse werden könnte ist die
Tatsache wenn die Berichte zu treffen
dass es doch größere Teile der
russischen Truppen gegeben hat die
geflohen sind die auch teilweise
Zivilkleidung anzogen und das deutet
natürlich auf eine erheblichen auf einen
erheblichen moralischen Tiefpunkt hin
wenn sich das fortsetzen sollte dann
wäre das in der Tat die Achillesferse
trotzdem warne ich vor zu verfrühter
Euphorie die Ursachen angekündigt dass
sie jetzt Gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen
insbesondere mit Luftstreitkräften
jetzt haben wir schon mal ein ziemlich
guten Überblick lassen sie uns
vielleicht in die Details gehen dazu
gibt schon mal eine ziemlich gute Frage
von Eduard mich würde mal Interessieren
schreibt er auf Youtube welche
strategische Bedeutung diese kleineren
Ortschaften haben kann man die Siege
taktisch ausnutzen oder mehr Richtung
Symbolkraft schreibt er
naja also jeder Raumgewinn hat natürlich
eine große Bedeutung für die
Gesamtoperation das ist klar wir müssen
jetzt auch unterscheiden zwischen
taktischen kleineren Vorstößen die es ja
immer schon gab auf beiden Seiten wo wir
mal die ein oder andere Ortschaft Namen
oder wieder verloren jetzt haben wir
eine Ebene höher das Ganze zu
veranschlagen das heißt wir sind auf der
operativen Ebene es gibt eine Erhebung
ein erheblichen operativen Erfolg ob er
am Ende eine strategische Wirkung
entfalten wird muss man sehen aber
zunächst mal ist ja auch schon allein
die moralische Wirkung von strategischer
Bedeutung und die Tatsache dass die
Ukraine die Russen in die Defensive
gedrängt hat zeigt ja auch schon in
welche Richtung es gehen kann es wäre
aber dennoch verfrüht jetzt von einer
strategischen Wende zu sprechen
selbst wenn Sie Fragen nach kleineren
Ortschaften die isum möglicherweise
kopians das sind natürlich insofern
wichtige Ortschaften als die logistische
Drehpunkte sind gibt es
Verkehrsknotenpunkte die von Bedeutung
sind allerdings nur wenn man sie selbst
in der Hand behält und nicht wenn der
Gegner sie hat insofern sind das eher
vorübergehende Erfolge ich glaube das
große Bild könnte sich aber ändern die
Frage wird sein ob die Ukraine genügend
Kraft haben um mit weiteren Reserven
diesen Angriff zu ernähren da bin ich
mir noch nicht so sicher das glaube ich
auch noch nicht aber sie werden
sicherlich alles tun um diese neue
Stelle und diese gewonnen haben zu
konsolidieren und welche Rolle wir
kommen auf die aktuelle Diskussion
können wir gleich noch zu sprechen aber
vielleicht bis zu diesem Punkt welche
Rolle haben westliche Waffenlieferungen
gespielt wir haben inwiefern haben die
den Ukrainern geholfen
also sie haben den Ukrainer natürlich
erheblich geholfen ich warne allerdings
immer davor die ukrainische
Widerstandskraft und auch die materielle
Kraft der Ukraine zu unterschätzen sie
waren schon zur Kriegsbeginn mit über
1000 Kampfpanzern 1200 Schützenpanzern
die zweitstärkste Armee Europas also
ohne die Türkei natürlich und das
bedeutet auch dass die Russen hier ein
hohes Risiko eingegangen sind natürlich
haben die Ukrainer viele Verluste gehabt
und die sind zum Teil auch durch den
Westen ersetzt worden insbesondere bei
der Artillerie bei der Luft Verteidigung
und die haben eine große Wirkung aber es
kommt glaube ich nicht nur auf die
Quantität hier an sondern auf die
Qualität die Reichweite westlicher
Geschütze ist eben höher als das was die
Ukraine bisher im Inventar hatten und
vor allen Dingen auch die Präzision aber
das muss man zu im Zusammenhang sehen
mit der Aufklärung und Ordnung und wenn
das im Verbund stimmt also Aufklärung
Auto und Kommunikation und schnelle
Reaktion dann kann die Artillerie gut
wirken und an alle diese Elemente muss
man denken und nicht nur ein
großwaffensysteme
ich habe es gerade schon angesprochen
diese jüngsten Erfolge haben jetzt
natürlich auch die Diskussion über
deutsche Waffenlieferungen wieder
angeheizt ja da geht es ja jetzt um die
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern der Kanzler
sagt keine angriffswachen Waffen und
Andreas Ruppert gibt uns da einen
Überblick
sie sind das Objekt der Begierde der
ukrainischen Militärs der deutsche
Kampfpanzer Leopard und der
Schützenpanzer Marder kommen ein Tag
vergeht an dem Kiew nicht fordert
liefert uns diese Waffensysteme eine
Bitte die bei der
Verteidigungsministerin bislang auf
taube Ohren stößt noch kein Land hat
schützen oder Kampfpanzer westlicher
Bauart geliefert und wir haben uns
darauf verständigt auch mit unseren
Partnern dass wir da keine deutschen
Alleingänge machen apropos Alleingänge
in der Ampelkoalition ist die SPD mit
dieser Haltung isoliert den Grüne und
FDP wollen schnellstmöglich auch
Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine liefern
ich wünschte mir dass die
Verteidigungsministerin ihre Linie
ändert es geht jetzt darum dass wir an
der Seite der Ukraine stehen jetzt ist
das Momentum entsprechende Waffen zu
Unterstützung zu liefern es ist klar
dass wir mehr liefern müssen auch
schweres Gerät und dass wir uns dabei
alles anschauen müssen auch die Bestände
der Bundeswehr die Bestände der
Industrie Forderungen die der
Bundeskanzler ablehnt beim Besuch des
israelischen Ministerpräsidenten behaart
Olaf Scholz darauf keine Angriffswaffen
keine Kampfpanzer
wir werden diesen Weg weitergehen und
die Ukraine so lange unterstützen wie
das notwendig ist und wir haben auch bei
verschiedenen Gelegenheiten sehr
angeboten dass wir bereit sind wenn es
um die langfristige Sicherheit der
Ukraine gibt gerade im Bereich
Artillerie und Luftverteidigung unseren
Beitrag zu leisten
Kampfpanzer für die Ukraine ja oder nein
diese Frage in zweit momentan die
Ampelkoalition
ja dazu schreibt Matthias auf Youtube
wann liefern wir endlich Marder und Leos
an die Ukraine die Politik muss langsam
liefern und dazu gibt es auch eine Frage
von einem User auf Youtube an Sie Herr
Richter für wie wahrscheinlich halten
Sie eine Lieferung von Leopard 2 Panzern
durch Deutschland und wie schwer ist es
für die ukrainischen Soldaten mit diesem
komplexen Kriegsgerät umzugehen
und ich fange mal mit der zweiten Frage
an natürlich ist es nicht leicht mit so
einem komplexen Kriegsgerät umzugehen
wenn es dann wirklich instand gesetzt
ist einsatzbereit ist und dann muss eben
die Ausbildung erfolgen diese Ausbildung
dauert mehrere Wochen es geht ja nicht
nur darum ein Panzer zu fahren sondern
ihn als System zu bedienen dann kommt
natürlich die Lieferung hinzu und die
Einführung in die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte also das alles
zusammenzählt muss man von mehreren
Wochen vielleicht auch zwei Monaten
ausgehen wenn man jetzt den Staat Knopf
drücken würde das sehe ich allerdings
noch nicht sie haben ja vorhin deutlich
gezeigt wie die Einstellung der
Bundesregierung dazu ist es ist
natürlich klar wenn deutsche
Leopard-Kampfpanzer wird also einer
typisch deutschen Signatur russische
Truppen über die Grenzen treiben dann
hat das eine ganz andere politische
Wirkung als wenn man so etwas im
Kombination im Verbund mit Alliierten
macht wird bis jetzt ist es richtig dass
wir noch nicht gesehen haben weder noch
Franzosen noch Amerikaner liefern
Kampfpanzer oder Schützenpanzer moderner
westlicher Bauart ich glaube wenn diese
Linie überschritten wird ich halte sie
nicht für sacrosank das kann man
überschreiten aber dann nur im Verbund
nur gemeinsam da wird es sicherlich
keine deutschen Alleingänge geben man
sollte aber auch nicht unterschätzen
dass die bisherigen Lieferungen von
artilleriesystemen von
flugabwehrsystemen doch ganz erheblich
war das ist ja auch der Bereich in dem
der Kanzler sagte dass man einen
deutschen Schwerpunkt bilden könnte und
das hat natürlich auch ganz erheblich
dazu beigetragen dass die im Verbund mit
anderen Lieferungen westlicher Partner
dass die Ukraine diese Erfolge hatten
also für mich ist die Lieferung von
Panzern keine endgültige rote Linie die
die überschritten werden kann aber
Deutsch Alleingänge wird es mit
Sicherheit dort nicht geben
soweit unser kleiner Diskurs über die
deutsche Diskussion über
Waffenlieferungen wir wollen wieder in
die Ukraine schauen und da hat
dirkwitter eine Frage war die erklärte
Offensive auf ressen nur eine Liste
damit die Russen Truppen verschieben
also der Angriff im Norden wohl schon
lange vorher geplant sie haben es eben
schon angedeutet
ja also ich würde es nicht nur als List
bezeichnen denn ich meine für beide
Operationen braucht man eine Menge an
Truppen die kann man die muss man
konzentrieren und das sollte eigentlich
für die Aufklärung des Gegners aus
sichtbar sein dass man dann am Ende den
eigentlichen Schwerpunkt im Nordosten
gewählt hat ist richtig und das hat ja
auch zum Erfolg geführt ich frage mich
allerdings wie man sich auf der
russischen Seite hat täuschen lassen
können denn wir Aufklärung sollte
funktionieren man muss ja Kräfte
verschieden man muss die Logistik
vorbereiten das sollte eine Aufklärung
eigentlich feststellen und wenn sie es
feststellt sollte man dann in der Lage
sein darauf zu reagieren das heißt
entweder die Logistik Linien zu
unterbrechen oder auch das Heranführen
von Reserven abzuregeln alles eine
Aufgabe erstmal der Luftstreitkräfte das
hat nicht geklappt dann eine Aufgabe
auch der Artillerie der weiterreichenden
Artillerie des Gefechts fällt eben auch
mit abzuregeln auch das hat nicht
geklappt hier scheint das Gegenfeuer der
ukrainischen Artillerie mit westlicher
Hilfe auch gut gewirkt zu haben und
insofern frage ich mich ob das wie das
ganze System der russischen Streitkräfte
also funktioniert
beginnen mit der Aufklärung mit der
Reaktion auf Aufklärungsergebnisse bis
hin zu der Koordination von
unterschiedlichen Verbänden
unterschiedlichen Waffensystemen was wir
so als Gefecht verbundener Waffen oder
verbundener Operationen bezeichnen da
scheint hier nicht zu funktionieren und
was noch schlimmer ist wahrscheinlich
aus Russland sind erste moralische
Einbrüche wenn wir haben schon auch so
etwas ähnliches gesehen am Anfang aber
diesmal scheint es gravierender zu sein
die Moral der russischen Truppen ist zum
Teil sehr niedrig das kann sich
natürlich auch um Verbände handeln die
eben nicht so den Besten gehören der der
nationalgerader etwa aber dennoch das
sind ernsthafte Anzeichen das könnte
sich langfristig als Achillesferse auch
zeigen oder einweisen und wir hören ja
auch aus Russland selber zum Beispiel
aus bestimmten Bezirken moskauz von
Stadträten dass die Kritik
man diese Operation auch öffentlich
geäußert wird
das heißt auch dass das russische
Militär jetzt massive Schwierigkeiten
mit Nachschub hat was könnte das für den
weiteren Kriegsverlauf bedeuten
ja also beide Seiten sind natürlich auf
Nachschub angewiesen und so ein Krieg
verschlingt ungeheure Mengen an Munition
tausende von Schuss unterschiedlichster
Kaliber jeden Tag und beide Seiten
werden ihre Schwierigkeiten haben diesen
Fluss aufrecht zu erhalten die Ukraine
ist immer mehr angewiesen auf westliche
Lieferungen die westlichen Staaten
europäischen aber auch die Amerikaner
sind nicht auf Kriegsproduktion
eingestellt bisher ich sehe auch keine
Zeichen dass das kommen wird das heißt
auch hier wird aus dem Bestand geschöpft
wir Russen greifen zurück auf sehr hohe
materielle Reserven die sie haben eine
wirkliche Umstellung auf
Kriegsproduktion ist aber auch noch
nicht erkennbar insbesondere die große
Mobilisierung hat noch nicht
stattgefunden aber immerhin man sieht
erste Anzeichen man will die russischen
Streitkräfte vermehren 137.000 Mann und
es sind auch offenbar Maßnahmen
getroffen worden um die Produktion zu
erhöhen denn auch die Russen können
nicht aus dem Unendlichen schöpfen aber
ich glaube die Frage wird eher sein
diese logistischen Güter an die Front zu
bringen und für die Ukrainer stellt sich
damit die Aufgabe das abzuregeln mit
weitreichenden Waffen insbesondere mit
der Artillerie und das zeigt auch wie
wichtig Artillerie Lieferungen sind
wir hören dass das russische Militär
jetzt verstärkt Luftangriffe auf ziviler
Einrichtungen fliegt in Rake wurde ein
Wohnhaus bombardiert könnte dieser Krieg
gerade wegen der russischen Verluste von
Moskau aus jetzt noch härter geführt
werden noch schmutziger werden
also ich bin etwas skeptisch diese
Waffensysteme die hier eingesetzt werden
sind nicht besonders präzise und in
einem Krieg der also sogenannte
Kollateralschaden in Kauf nimmt wo man
also mit großen streuwirkungen auch
rechnet wird immer auch zivile
Einrichtungen treffen wir wissen nicht
den Kontext wir kennen wir wissen nicht
was das wirkliche Ziel war aber es wird
diese diese Einschläge geben und das in
Kauf zu nehmen ist die eigentliche
moralische Frage die sich hier stellt
ich glaube weniger daran dass gezielt
zivile Einrichtungen angegriffen werden
dafür sind die Systeme viel zu
unpräziser als dass man das tun könnte
letzte Frage an Sie Herr Richter unter
welchen Voraussetzungen was braucht die
Ukraine um ihre militärischen Erfolge
weiter voranzutreiben und auch halten zu
können
ja Sie werden sicherlich zunächst einmal
weiterhin eine starke Luftverteidigung
brauchen sie haben sich bisher in ihre
Luftverteidigung durchaus bewährt es gab
Lieferungen aus westlichen Staaten
zunächst mal auch aus der Slowakei
ehemaliges sowjetische Systeme die
passen in das logistische System der
Ukraine die erst 300 dann aber jetzt
werden natürlich auch Systeme geliefert
größere Art die aus Deutschland und den
USA kommen die werden die
Luftverteidigung erheblich verbessern es
hat seit Kriegsbeginn die Schulter
gefeuerten Waffen gegeben die gut sind
um die russischen luftradkräfte in der
Höhe zu treiben sie wirken natürlich nur
bis zu einer Höhe von vielleicht 3000
Metern aber das bedeutet auch dass
solche Angriffe dann eben ungenauer
werden und insofern ist die
Luftverteilung nach wie vor ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt den man sehen muss bis
jetzt haben die Ukraine noch
ausreichende Zahlen an schützen und
Kampfpanzern gehabt selbst oder auch
bekommen von Polen von den Slowaken und
anderen ob da in Zukunft mehr nötig sein
wird und die Beweglichkeit unter Feuer
zu erhalten wird man sehen das ist die
Frage die sich dann an den Westen stellt
ob man dann die das haben wir gerade
diskutiert diese rote Linie dann doch
überschreitet und eben kam von
Schützenpanzern liefert vielen Dank
Oberst ad Richter ich wünsche Ihnen noch
einen schönen Abend tschüss danke
vielmals einen schönen Abend danke schön
ja das ist für das russische Militär in
der Ukraine gerade nicht gut läuft dass
es auch mittlerweile in Russland
angekommen Kritik wird immer lauter auch
an Präsident Putin Isabel Thymian
diese Bilder soll die Welt sehen Männer
vom russischen Geheimdienst FSB
verhaften angebliche ukrainische Spione
präsentieren Waffen und führen sie ab
die Männer sollen Terrorangriffe auf
russische Stützpunkte auf der Krim
geplant haben
russlandsführung braucht
Erfolgsmeldungen denn seit Anfang
September hat das ukrainische Militär
offenbar deutliche Geländegewinne
erzielt
die Ukrainer wiederum zeigen erbeutete
russische Panzer Essensreste und
Kleidung
erklärt heute Putin sei immer informiert
von den Aktivitäten in der Ukraine in
Russland spricht man von Umgruppierung
der Truppen Umgruppierung so heißt hier
das was andere Rückzug nennen
am Wochenende waren Regionalwahlen in
Russland die Kandidaten des Kreml haben
wie erwartet klar gewonnen doch aus
einem Moskauer Bezirk gibt es Kritik an
Putin
ihre Rhetorik ist pure Aggression und
das hat uns in die Zeiten des Kalten
Krieges zurückversetzt die Welt hat
wieder angefangen sich vor Russland zu
fürchten und es zu hassen und Russland
bedroht die Welt wieder mit
Nuklearwaffen
und dann bitten Sie Putin er möge doch
zurücktreten
bröckelt Putins macht wird die Kritik an
ihm auch inner russisch lauter
auch dieser Mann meldet sich am
Wochenende zu Wort der Chef der
russischen Teilrepublik Tschetschenien
Ramsan kadirov er kritisiert den Kreml
für militärische Fehlschläge ein
ungewöhnlicher Affront eines Mannes der
Putins Bluthund genannt wird und noch im
Juli und August Truppen in die Ukraine
geschickt hat
[Musik]
Vladimir Putin äußert sich heute nur zu
den Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Russland
die verfolgen die Taktik eines
ökonomischen blitzkriegs aber der
funktioniert nicht das ist für jeden
ersichtlich
eigentlich wollte der Kreml in Teilen
der besetzten Gebiete der Ukraine ballt
Referenten abhalten über einen Anschluss
an Russland doch diese Pläne so hört man
sein auf unbestimmte Zeit verschoben
ja bröckelt die russische Unterstützung
für den Präsidenten so langsam oder
bekommt sie zumindest Risse darüber
wollen wir sprechen mit dem
russland-experten und Blogger Niko lange
guten Abend
lange alle Welt spricht von Rückzug die
Russisch der russischen Truppen Russland
von einer Umgruppierung und von einer
Verringerung militärischer Aktivität
funktioniert diese Propaganda überhaupt
noch
diese Propaganda funktioniert nicht es
ist ja sogar von das ist eine schöne
Wortschöpfung von einem negativen
Angriff gesprochen worden
jeder in Russland versteht dass das ein
militärischer Misserfolg ist und es hat
natürlich in Russland auch eine ganze
Menge an Diskussionen ausgelöst wobei
besonders bemerkenswert ist dass sogar
im staatlichen Fernsehen also ein Medium
das einer sehr sehr intensiven Kontrolle
unterliegt jetzt abweichende Meinungen
zu den vorherigen geäußert worden sind
also es tut sich was in Russland
sie sprechen das gerade an wir haben
vorhin diese Talkshow schon gezeigt
einige Bilder es gab eben diese Talkshow
im russischen Staatsfernsehen in der ja
ziemlich offen Kritik an der
Staatsführung ausgesprochen wurde und
wurde deutliche Worte kann mehr vor
allem von den Politiker Boris na der
stehen das ist doch relativ ungewöhnlich
dass so offen Kritik an der Führung
geäußert wird was sagt das über die
aktuelle Situation aus
Putin hat ja das System der Medien
systematisch der Kontrolle unterworfen
und uns besondere das Fernsehen spielt
im System Putin eine ganz ganz wichtige
Rolle insofern kann im Fernsehen nur
gesagt werden was erlaubt ist oder das
weiß auch jeder der an solchen
Fernsehsendungen teilnehmen insofern ist
das ganz besonders bemerkenswert dass
diese Äußerungen gemacht worden sind und
besonders bemerkenswert finde ich an
dieser Aussage von Matthi dass er auf
die Diskussion gehen ob in der Krieg
sehr lange dauern würde gesagt hat naja
was ihr hier alle sagt das haben also
auch meine
zehnjährigen
und dass das im russischen Fernsehen
gesendet wurde
ist zumindest mein Hinweis darauf dass
Diskussionen begonnen haben vielleicht
aber auch ein Hinweis dass jetzt
schleichend abweichende Meinungen
zugelassen werden weil man sich
kommunikativ auf eine Veränderung dieses
Krieges und vielleicht auch eine
Veränderung des russischen Vorgehens
einstellt
russische Soldaten sollen geflohen sein
Material zurückgelassen haben es gibt
mittlerweile hämische Kommentare dass
die Russen aktuell der der größte
Waffenlieferant für die Ukraine sein was
macht das mit den Menschen in Russland
was was ändert sich da gerade
ja viele Russen haben glaube ich die
Überzeugung gehabt dass Russland auf
jeden Fall stärker ist als die Ukraine
und sie versuchen jetzt Erklärungen zu
finden die offizielle Propaganda gibt ja
an dass die Russen im Grunde gegen die
NATO kämpfen würden und da werden
ständig neue Dinge erfunden welche
Waffen und welche Nato-Soldaten dann
eigentlich auf ukrainischer Seite
kämpfen damit man nicht zugeben muss
dass die Ukraine eben stark ist und dass
die Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine ihr Land
verteidigen
viele der Russinnen und Russen haben
glaube ich aber auch gehofft dass
Russland diesen Krieg für sich
entscheiden kann damit er schnell
vorbeigeht und damit die damit
verbundenen Belastungen nicht so stark
auf sie einen eintreffen und
gleichzeitig ist es glaube ich
mittlerweile so dass in vielen
russischen Familien zumindest vom
Hörensagen im familiärenkreis bekannt
geworden ist das Soldaten gefallen sind
verletzt worden sind oder vermisst
werden in der Ukraine und die russische
Gesellschaft beschäftigt sich mit dieser
Frage heimlich still und leise weil man
weiß sobald man nur von Krieg spricht
kann man bis zu 15 Jahre ins Gefängnis
kommen aber gestern zum Beispiel in
dieser Fernsehsendung wo sie Ausschnitte
gezeigt haben ist ja von den Beteiligten
sogar von Krieg gesprochen worden
insofern kommt da jetzt einiges auch an
Propaganda ins Rutschen man kann doch
nicht einschätzen wohin das führt aber
man sieht es bröckelt und autoritäre
Systeme total Ökosysteme wie das in
Russland die sind ja immer so lange
stabil bis sie es plötzlich nicht mehr
sind und es gar nicht so einfach
einzuschätzen was da jetzt hinter den
Kulissen passiert
es bröckelt ja oder oder Gegenwind kommt
ja von Seiten von Gegnern dieses Krieges
es gibt aber auch
ultra-nationalistische Stimmen im Land
die sagen wie konntet ihr diese
spezialoperation wie das dort genannt
werden muss vergeigen und fordern jetzt
eine
generalimmobilmachung das wäre auch eine
Frage von Bora auf Youtube könnte die
jetzt in Russland erfolgen
zunächst mal muss man klar festhalten
das was häufig behauptet behauptet wird
Putin müsse nur eine generalmobil machen
und dann würde er den Krieg gewinnen ist
falsch also die generalprobiermachung
ist kein siegsknopf den Putin hat er hat
gute Gründe warum er die general mobil
machen vermeidet vor allen Dingen weil
er die Kritik der
Eliten der besser gebildeten Russen in
den großen Städten den aufgerollt in St
Petersburg in Moskau fürchtet und ich
meine die
lokalabgeordneten aus Moskau und aus St
Petersburg wo er mittlerweile 18 einen
Aufruf zum Rücktritt Putins
unterschrieben haben weisen ja noch mal
darauf hin welche Gefahren so eine
Generalmobilmachung eigentlich hat für
Putin also ich glaube nicht dass er
diesen Schritt gehen wird weil er die
innenpolitische Gegenwelle fürchtet
Ralf schreibt auf Facebook Putin hat so
umfassend versagt das wird die russische
Führungsschicht nicht mehr lange
akzeptieren wie würden sie das
einschätzen
die russische Führungsschicht ist ja
vielfältig und ich glaube es beginnt
jetzt schon eine Diskussion wer
eigentlich verantwortlich dafür ist es
gibt derzeit in Moskau Diskussionen über
die Frage wer waren eigentlich
diejenigen die Putin zu dieser
Militärmission geraten haben wer waren
eigentlich diejenigen die ihm gesagt
haben die Ukrainer würden keinen
Widerstand leisten also da merkt man
schon da wird nach Schuldigen gesucht es
gibt aber auch Streit hinter den
Kulissen zwischen den Militärs und dem
Geheimdienstlern wo viele der Militärs
der Auffassung sind naja Putin und seine
Geheimdienstleute die haben uns diesen
Krieg eingebrockt und die haben das auf
der Grundlage falsche Erkenntnisse getan
und dieser Konflikt könnte sich
verschärfen
bemerkenswert sind auch darauf haben sie
hingewiesen die radikalen
nationalistischen Kräfte die sagen der
Krieg wird im Grunde zu schwach geführt
er muss jetzt noch viel stärker gefühlt
werden also Kritik an Putin und Kritik
an der russischen Vorgehensweise in der
Ukraine kommt jetzt aus mehreren
Richtungen gleichzeitig und von Seiten
der Staatsführung ist ja bis jetzt noch
nicht allzu viel gekommen die mit Free
mit WTF früherer Regierungschef und
enger Vertrauter von Putin schreibt
heute auf seinem telegram Kanal
folgendes das schauen wir uns kurz an
ein gewisser silenski sagte er führe
keinen Dialog mit denjenigen die
Ultimaten Stellen dieses Ultimatum ist
ein Kinderspiel gemessen an den
zukünftigen Forderungen und diese sind
ihm bekannt die totale Kapitulation des
kiew-regimes zu den Bedingungen
Russlands
was sagt das aus wenn jemand der in der
Kritik steht so ausholt
ich glaube damit Videos hat sich nicht
zum Besseren verändert und man kann ihn
eigentlich gar nicht mehr so richtig
ernst nehmen mit den radikalen
Äußerungen die er ständig von sich gibt
interessant ist aber wenn man den
zwischen den Zeilen in den Text hinein
sieht das mit Video und auch andere Test
in den letzten Tagen immer wieder von
Verhandlungen sprechen das haben die
lange nicht gemacht und sie machen es
auch an einem seltsamen Kontext und sie
versuchen trotzdem noch so zu tun als
wären sie in einer Position der Stärke
aber sie erwähnen das Wort Verhandlungen
und das ist sicherlich ein Ergebnis der
ukrainischen erfolgreichen militärischen
Operationen was ja beweist eine These
die schon lange diskutiert wurde dass
wenn die Ukraine stark genug ist wenn
sie sich militärisch durchsetzen kann
dann kann sie die Wahrscheinlichkeit von
Verhandlungen und letztlich auch von
Frieden erhöhen
fühlen wir uns vielleicht zum Schluss
noch einmal vor Augen Russland wollte
die Ukraine innerhalb weniger Tage
überrennen und jetzt
herrscht dort seit mehr als einem halben
Jahr Krieg und die Ukraine erobert
Gebiete zurück kann diese Entwicklung
Putin gefährlich werden das haben wir
heute abend klären würden können oder
macht das Putin noch gefährlicher wenn
er mit dem Rücken zur Wand steht
meiner Meinung nach ist es ein Mythos
das Putin unbegrenzt eskalieren könnte
man sieht es ja gerade an diesen
Gegenangriffen man sieht es daran auch
dass mittlerweile
die Partner der Ukraine darunter auch
Deutschland sehr weitreichende und sehr
leistungsstarke Waffen liefern und keine
der befürchteten Eskalationen ist
eingetreten es gibt sehr heftige
rhetorische Drohungen wie von zum
Beispiel Herrn Medvedev aber das ist für
mich eher in Zeiten Zeichen der Schwäche
wenn man solche radikalen Äußerungen
machen muss also ich glaube nicht dass
es da eine Möglichkeit gibt überhaupt
noch weiter zu eskalieren innerhalb
Russlands ist es so dass Putin das
Mediensystem kontrolliert und die
Opposition über viele Jahre
ausgeschaltet hat das heißt wenn er das
Thema wechselt oder zum Beispiel die
spezialoperation für beendet erklärt ist
eigentlich nicht damit zu rechnen dass
es da große Widerstand gegen ihn geben
wird also er hat die Lage was betrifft
glaube ich immer noch sehr im Griff aber
natürlich steht Putin und stehen auch
die militärischen Führer dieser
spezialoperation auf der russischen
Seite jetzt vor der Frage wie können sie
eigentlich weiter damit umgehen dass die
Ukraine so erfolgreich ist militärisch
sind Sie in der Lage die Front noch mal
zu stabilisieren oder die Initiative
wieder zu bekommen das ist im Moment
offene Fragen aber die sind auch mit der
Frage verbunden kann Putin eigentlich
die politischen Ziele für diesen Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine
aufrechterhalten und
wir haben vorhin festgestellt es
bröckelt ein wenig und da sind jetzt die
Diskussionen glaube ich in vollem Gange
und ich fand es bemerkenswert dass Putin
gestern nach einem Bericht der
moscotimes nicht dazu bereit war die
militärische Führung und die russischen
Generäle überhaupt zu treffen also da
hängt offenbar auch der Haussegen schief
und da muss man jetzt beobachten ob es
da überhaupt noch eine Möglichkeit gibt
da wieder Ordnung hineinzubringen
verlange ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich
für das Gespräch und die Einblicke die
Sie uns geben konnten machen sie es gut
tschüss
schönen Abend
danke schön und auch Ihnen und Euch
einen schönen Abend noch und wie immer
besten Dank für alle Fragen und
Kommentare ich möchte zum Schluss noch
einen von Micha auf Youtube Vorlesen
diese sehr plötzliche Wende hat mich
überrascht aber ich bin was Militär und
Strategie angeht auch ahnungslos aber
ich freue mich sehr für die unschuldigen
Menschen macht's gut bis bald tschüss